bonsoir stéphane villain merci d'être
avec nous on le voit les restrictions
qui ont plutôt tendance à se multiplier
cas se réduire mais le heureusement
est-ce que vous avez des personnes vous
des départements confiné qui sont venus
se réfugier chez vous parce que tout le
monde nous dit paris se vide par exemple
mais vous savez en fait 30 % de notre
clientèle habituellement et bien sûr de
l'ile-de-france très très heureux d
accueillir oui effectivement
actuellement on le voit bien dans notre
département il y à de nombreux parisiens
qui viennent dans leur résidence
secondaire c'est le département de
charente maritime
c'est 95 mille résidents secondaires
donc quand il est question de pandémie
comme ça plutôt que de rester dans des
petits appartements et bien viennent
chez nous il ya des grands espaces et
les grandes plages il ya de quoi
effectivement s'aérer on est très très
contents de l'accueillir
alors ça veut dire que le deux dents
avec les miens dehors avait en citoyen
c'est le fameux slogan du gouvernement
ça s'applique parfaitement votre
département
bien sûr vous savez on a département
avec 470 km de côtes avec des îles
magnifiques avec une campagne
remarquable il ya de quoi s'aérer nous
mêmes on a réussi en fait en plus un
taux très faible de kovy donc c'est
plutôt une bonne chose
et puis en incapacité à accueillir les
gens dans des meilleures conditions
il suffit simplement que les gens qui
viennent nous visiter respecte les
protocoles
vous savez les mesures sanitaires les
barrières ce qui se fait très bien
d'ailleurs quand les gens viennent chez
nous ils respect que les pédagogues mais
on est très très content c'est de
l'économie qui rentre bien sûr ce
département de la charente maritime
donc bienvenue chez nous bienvenue chez
vous fait un discours plutôt joyeux et
voilà un petit peu léger qui tranche
avec celui qu'ont d'autres parfois
communes qui nous disons dallas on veut
pas des parisiens chez nous ils vont
nous nous contaminer ans ce département
en rouge va venir nous apporter le virus
nous n'est pas dans cet état d'esprit et
c'est le chaos de vos administrés
mais comment vous voulez en fait que
longueur d'année on essaye de faire en
sorte d'attirer les populations
parisienne vous savez les gens qui
viennent chez nous c'est la 10 c'est à
dire ça va de paris orléans tours niort
poitiers en fait c'est ça
clientèle on va pas leur dire mais quand
tout va bien on va faire en sorte de
vous accueillir dans les meilleures
conditions
et puis quand tout va mal vous restez
chez vous non c'est pas sérieux
donc nous on est très très contents de
les accueillir et puis vous savez on a
département il faut en fait voilà faut
vivre vous animez faux faux faux faux
moi vous savez aujourd'hui je me suis un
anniversaire ce soir d'une personne n'a
dit à pékin qui fête ses 60 ans et bien
voilà on se rend on se réunit on se
retrouve on respecte les gestes
barrières on fait attention mais je
pense assez important bienvenue chez
nous moi je suis très content qu'ils
aient tué alors donc ça veut dire que
vous n'avez pas ces rassemblements
proscrits à plus de 2 6 personnes vous
vivez à peu près normalement si on vous
suit bien vous allez nous donnait rien
on va être là janot attention on fait
attention bien sûr quand je vous dis que
je suis l anniversaire on est six ans
n'est pas plus et c'est sa fête la ville
c'est à dire que il faut pas que tout
s'arrête
il faut effectivement qu'on continue à
vivre il faut que voilà on est capacité
à faire en sorte de tout en respectant
les juste derrière de vivre de faire
attention alors c'est vrai que nous on
est très très content de continuer à le
dire de continuer à vivre
vous savez le département de charente
maritime aujourd'hui il a un taux
d'incident je lui ai dit tout à l'heure
qui est très faible
tout simplement parce que les gens mais
quand ils font la fête il respectait
justement alors y'en a qui sont moins
contents ce sont les gendarmes qui font
des contrôles plusieurs dizaines
d'automobilistes venant de ses 16 un
département confiné ont été verbalisés
le week-end dernier pour non respect des
règles de restriction
c'est normal selon vous il faut faire
ces contrôles
mais je crois qu'en fait si vous voulez
il faut respecter la loi aussi c'est à
dire qu'à partir du moment où on a dit
aux gens il faut que maintenant vous
aurez une partie plus de chez vous c'est
à dire c'était le vendredi et le samedi
matin
oui je pense qu'il fallait respecter la
loi c'est bien normal par ailleurs ayant
un peu d'un juge savez aujourd'hui on
est dans un contexte difficile
anxiogène où les genres et là se pose
mille questions de savoir quel va être
le nom le lendemain si l'on capacité à
aller sur des territoires qui sont allés
à peu moins avril
comme idée si je puis dire tant mieux
donc non je vais demander en fait
finalement et je les lis moi la police
municipale je les dis aussi à la
gendarmerie si amical soyons indulgents
faisons en sorte que les gens puissent
vivre normalement retrouver un semblant
de vie respectons barça je me mets le
l'accent dessus bien sûr bien sûr toutes
les sous les barrières mais quand il y
aura vraiment et je peux vous dire que
j'ai qu'une hâte c'est que l'on fasse de
la vaccination de masse et que au mois
de juillet j'espère on puisse retrouver
une vie dans 20 en france
justement comment ça fera c'est vous je
crois qu'il ya 6000 habitants dans votre
commune
comment ça se passe au niveau de la
vaccination mais en fait on a sorte
d'excitation à châtelaillon on est à peu
près plus de 2000 de vacciner c'est un
peu compliqué on demande des doses
supplémentaires et on sait que c'est
compliqué aussi pour l'état
on accompagne vraiment le mouvement
c'est à dire qu'on n'est pas là pour
crier au scandale quand on n'a pas de
dose
parce que là on sait que tout ça est
difficile tout ça est compliqué mais on
espère simplement que voilà au fur et à
mesure des mois qu'ils vont s'écouler on
va être là pas citer d'accueillir mais à
ces personnes de moins de 70 ans
maintenant
et puis avec des moins de 65 ans au fur
et à mesure voilà des mois qu'ils vont
s'écouler pour que l'on puisse tous se
retrouver en fait voilà une vie normale
à partir de ce mois de juillet comme je
disais qu'on puisse tous retrouvés sur
la plage n'est ce pas merci on aimerait
bien mais voilà merci aux stéphanois on
n'a pas le droit de quitter
effectivement appelé de de 10 kilomètres
quand on est en ile de france qui est
notre cas merci à vous